thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you are with us Anthony is with
us in Yakima Washington
hi Anthony how are you better than I
deserve sir how can I help so I got a
little bit Lema I'm 22 years old I got
not scammed but I did one of those real
estate seminars and ended up getting
approved for you know credit cards and
use that to paid off about twenty five
thousand dollars in those credit cards
for that real estate training program at
the same time same here I open up my own
insurance agency you pay like $25,000
for a real estate training program yes I
did with who well it was at record owned
are you event okay Alex yeah so I mean
that and so that's to train you to that
was supposed to train you to do what to
learn how to wholesale properties and
slip in and buy homes okay all right and
so you have $25,000 on your credit cards
from that so it was $25,000 for just a
real estate program then I had to go
through capital who financed this I mean
I had to give them another $3,000 to be
able to provide me with what's funding
for those cards and they were supposed
to be interest-free card and the plan
was to make those 20 pay that $25,000
awesome you know before the year was up
but it's been over a year so now I'm
paying interest on all those cards okay
I'm curious at any point in that process
did you not think that was high yes I
thought about it the whole time but I
don't know I just I said I'm ready broke
I can't get one book but apparently I
will you can you got 25,000 more broke
Oh Lord okay so what do you do for a
living today I'm gonna turn agent okay
so you did open your insurance
company correct okay and are you making
money um well I I am but I mean most of
it goes to pillows most of they goes to
those expenses so you're not making much
money no not much money yeah how much
are you making this year I shouldn't
make about 60 K well that's not too bad
that's more than I would have guessed
okay all right and so no because I mean
I don't have a mortgage or anything
that's yeah yeah but if you make 60 K
and you pay your taxes you're gonna pay
that 25 more real fast if you don't
spend any money yes this is my question
I've been contemplated between filing a
bankruptcy you're not bankrupt
go away from this 25,000 you're not
bankrupt where is your 60,000 going well
my staff I have a part-time guy that
works for me
and then so I'm gonna ask you broke up
after I heard part-time guy didn't hear
what you said okay I have a part-time
job that works for me I have a car
payment I also have my student loans how
much do you owe MMR on my car about
17,000 and how much you owe on your
student loan 10,000 and then another
20,000 in this insurance business what
do you mean you okay I acquired an
agency I quite an agency slice I bought
a small book of business I see okay I
don't I don't know if you can afford a
guy part-time working for you unless you
start making more money
mm-hmm I don't think you can afford him
right now and you probably need to sell
your car and move down in car
dramatically but the only way you would
file bankruptcy is if you give up your
car you give up the insurance agency and
you wipe everything clean but the
student loans it would be the only way
you file bankruptcy but I don't think
that's what needs to happen here I think
you need to work her way out of this
I think you need to get I think you need
to double your number of hours that
you're working and you really need to
turn on the steam and pour out the calls
if you've gone from zero to sixty
thousand pretty quick here at 22 years
old I think you can kick this on up so
let's work our butts off and get this on
up to seventy eighty nine D and throwing
all of it at these debts and I think you
can clear these debts up then you're
gonna have no life for a little while
but you've done a couple of really
stupid things in a row like three of
them you bought a car you could afford
you bought an insurance agency you
couldn't afford you got ripped off with
an insurance class and all of that
totals almost a hundred grand at 22
years old so it's gonna take you a
little while to dig out but if you dig
out and end up with this insurance
agency this book of business clear and
you don't know anything on and you don't
know anything on your car and you don't
know anything on these credit cards you
pay off your student loans dude you're
gonna be sitting pretty but that means
you're going to work the next two to
three years with no life and you're
gonna work like an angry madman getting
after it and clean this mess up and
that's really what needs to happen here
and then if you don't want to stay in
the insurance business you will have
built that book of business up and
you'll be able to sell it for a
substantial profit I mean there's
possibility you could work with the guy
you're working with and hand him that
book of business back if you had a
different career track and get out of
that twenty thousand dollars worth of
debt if you wanted to that would be
another way of clearing some debt but um
you know you got a sixty thousand dollar
income which is no slouch income for
twenty two that's not bad you just
you're spending it all out so you need
to get on a written budget you need to
increase your income and you need to
decide if you're gonna stay in the
insurance business and if you are then
let's get let's just turn it up just
turn up the heat and let's get this mess
cleaned up hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh